Andrew Tate bought me tickets to fly to
Romania where there's a rumor online
that we hooked up that didn't happen do
you think you made any mistakes in that
venture
here here's conception one I am what I
believe but as soon as your belief
collapses well then who are you at least
think it through the belief in God is
Not adherence to a set of semantic
propositions what do people do if
something they fundamentally believe
changes I don't know who the hell you
are and neither do you when people say
they want to be happy they actually
don't know what they mean that's why you
think you think so that your stupid
thoughts can die instead of you okay
let's switch directions I'm not very
fond of the whole online porn thing in
any way I've got all these hoes and look
at me who said Tate's intelligent and
what that means as well is that some of
the things he says are going to be of
value now why he says those that's a
whole different issue he's genuinely
tough it's better to be a monster than a
rabbit in some ways the more you could
embrace the worst enemy the more
radically you could transform for the
better so would you talk to him well
[Music]
dad welcome to my podcast yeah well I'm
glad to be here it's good to see you're
getting it going again yeah finally but
thank you for being the intro back into
the online world I'm looking forward to
it kiddo so
I think it was last week I saw a video
going around of you describing the worst
breakfast you've ever had your breakfast
oh yeah that's a funny one yeah yeah and
that has millions of views and it
reminded me of going to the restaurant
near our house when we were kids and I
remember one time you didn't like your
breakfast and you got up and taught the
cook how to cook so I thought we could
open with
you did that why did that amuse you
because a normal person would
quietly complain about their breakfast
with other people at the table and then
eat most of it out of guilt and then not
come back and you did not do that okay
so yeah so this is a little restaurant
little diner by our house yeah cost and
I knew the owner and I liked her
and I liked going there for breakfast I
used to bring my graduate students there
and we'd have breakfast there and we had
meetings that were very productive and
that breakfast was excellent and so what
does that mean it means that the
potatoes were fresh and that they were
cooked crispy and golden and not brown
and Soggy and horrible and old and
sometimes rotten because you can do all
those if you really want to and the
orange juice was like made out of
oranges instead of whatever the hell
they fed astronauts in 1957 and the
coffee was fresh and the bacon was
actually made out of pork instead of
whatever the hell you make bacon out of
when you don't have a pig and uh
it was good and so I liked coming there
and I liked the woman she's hard-working
immigrant woman and she ran a good
restaurant it was very welcoming and
they had a great cook and then they
brought in this new guy and it was like
second rate and I thought
it doesn't have to be second rate maybe
he's lazy in which case he should go or
maybe he just doesn't know what the hell
he's doing and I thought well I don't
want to be pissed off about this and
never come back and Grumble about it I'd
rather come here and have a good
breakfast so I thought well and I worked
as a short order cook for years and knew
the difference between how to cook you
know
that hash browns properly and improperly
and I went in and told them like what
was wrong in detail why this didn't work
and what he could do instead and you
know he responded positively because I
wasn't going in there giving him hell I
was doing exactly what I just told you
it's like I wanted to go to this
restaurant it was all set up I liked the
woman and he might as well do it right
and so that's what I did I thought that
was a music video it was really funny
did breakfast
breakfast improved very dramatically
yeah yeah yeah
it's funny yeah so there was no downside
to that too you know because you go out
to a place and you don't get treated
well it just pisses you off and then you
don't say anything because you're so
polite and you know it's understandable
to some degree but it's not helpful
because then you go away and you're
irritated because you didn't get what
you bargained for and then you don't go
back and if that happens to a small
business it doesn't have to happen that
often and people just don't go and then
if the you know maybe the owner doesn't
even know and so then their business
vanishes out from underneath them and
that's not helpful you know if he would
have got all uppity in squawky about it
that wouldn't have gone well but I
wasn't being mean
and you know when I wasn't trying to
like parade my knowledge of hash browns
around I just wanted to keep going to
that Diner so yeah all right it's it's a
little bit funny it yeah I guess it's a
little bit funny I suppose yeah yeah uh
so I thought we should no the other
thing about that too is like if you're
at a restaurant and you have good
service
it's really helpful to tell the people
what they did right in detail and this
is a good thing to know in your life in
general like if you go somewhere and
people go a bit out of their way to make
it go well for you and you tell them
what they did in detail and you thank
them for it they're so happy you can't
believe it and then they're way more
likely to do that again in the future
because there isn't anything BF Skinner
figured this out a Skinner taught
Skinner could teach an animal to do
anything Skinner taught rats to dance
and to climb ladders and to pack on
photographs to guide missiles and that
was pigeons and oh wow yeah yeah Skinner
could teach animals to do anything and
he said you can teach an animal using
threat so that produces anxiety you can
use punishment like electric shock minor
electric shock the behaviors would do
that which isn't as harsh as it sounds
because it's you know minor irritant
essentially or you can use reward now
reward is hard to use eh because if
you're going to teach an animal by using
reward you have to watch them and then
you have to wait till you see them do
something that you want them to repeat
and then you have to reward them right
there and that so you have to be a very
very attentive to use reward and so
often people don't use reward in their
lives because they don't pay enough
attention or maybe they're afraid to
actually communicate what they want but
it's unbelievably powerful and so if you
watch your kids
or your wife your friends
and I don't mean to do this
manipulatively because that's stupid but
if they do something that you would like
to see repeated and you notice it you
think oh that went real well you went
out of your way you stepped up you
improved your performance even if it's
just a minor Improvement sort of on the
edge if you
identify that describe it in detail and
call it out
it's so motivating for people you just
can't believe it you can just call out
the best in people constantly by doing
that you can do it to yourself too you
know if you've noticed that you've made
a little progress forward instead of
bitching at yourself about how you're
slightly less useless than you once were
you know and sort of damn with faint
praise you can notice that you took a
step however small in the right
direction and you know treat yourself
with a bit of appreciation and
consequence it's one of the things you
teach people if you're a behavioral
psychologist is to teach them how to
reward themselves just taking
incremental steps towards their desired
goal yep do you think
that works for people across the board
or do you think some people react more
to punishment
no it's it's
some people don't react at all to
punishment
like Julian your brother was a good
example of that is he was just too
ornery and tough to to react really he
didn't react well to punishment we used
to use time out on them because you can
use time out on kids he was way more
responsive to reward
um you were more sensitive to punishment
in that with you when you were a little
kid really all I had to do was you know
point my finger at you and look and
you'd stop Julian that was like that was
just an invitation to tangle for him so
but reward fundamentally reward you want
to use threat and Punishment sparingly
very very sparingly you know you bring
up the big guns only when necessary and
but reward is
it's so useful and
but it requires careful focal attention
you know and I think Scarlet's like that
she hardly needs it like if you just
look at her sideways when she's done
something wrong she cries right yeah
right right not in like a depressed way
you know what did I do wrong oh my gosh
yeah well that cry so the way your
nervous system works basically this is
one of the ways you learn is that
imagine that there's a sequence of
activation of neurons in a pattern like
like a musical pattern right and so
whenever you're manifesting a given
Behavior there's a symphony of neurons
that are firing
that accompany that or that precede it
now
if the Symphony of neural pattern
produces a desired outcome
then that produces a release of dopamine
and the dopamine does two things is one
it makes you feel good and the second is
that it makes the neurons that were most
recently active grow the connections
between them and strengthen sort of in
proportion to how like the the farther
back in time they were activated the
less dopamine they're flooded by so any
behavioral pattern neural pattern that's
resulted in a positive consequence gets
bathed in dopamine and then strengthens
it's like the weight strengthening in a
large language model it's the same thing
and so if you reward people for
um performing properly then what they
did is reinforced by the dopamine as
well as rewarded so the reinforcement is
the growth and the reward is the
subjective feeling
and if you punish them for it we don't
exactly know how punishment works
neurologically or at least I don't know
but it weakens the connections and kills
the patterns and I think that the
feeling of negative emotion that is
associated with failure let's say is
actually a signal of the death of part
of you right the impending death feels
Awakening or something yeah it kind of
feels like that it's part of it that's
dying or weakening right so it has to
give up and it's painful right yeah that
that's why a radical personality
transformation you know if you fail
dreadfully so imagine you fail in a
marriage let's say because it's betrayed
the what you failed at is a pattern
that's co-activated with almost
everything you do right because if
you're married to someone the fact that
you're married married is a predicate of
everything that you're involved in the
way you look at the world the way you
think about yourself the way you conduct
yourself and then when that collapses
all of that is punished all of it and so
well that's enough of a death you know
if you're like 75 years old and your
wife dies there's a real high
probability you'll die in the next year
this just takes you out you know and
even if it doesn't if you're younger a
big party is going to die and that's
very very painful that grief and that
reconstitution that's all a partial
death and it can kill you right can be
so stressful that you just die but if
you don't a lot of you has to die and
then hypothetically you know re-emerge
it takes a long time for the death like
a year and a long time for the
re-emergence sometimes you don't
re-emerge either you just end up you
know three quarters dead and that's what
happens with ideological beliefs too
right why people get stuck in it because
in order to change your frame of thought
a piece if you has to die yeah well no
it's worse than that a piece you has to
die and it might be a lot of you but
also when that piece dies it's not like
it's replaced immediately by a new
functional piece you lose the chaos
that's right that's the desert we just
released this Exodus seminar right and
one of the things that happens to the
Israelites once they leave the tyranny
of Egypt they under lost in the desert
of course that's part of the mystery of
the story it's like it's not a very big
desert that where they're lost it
wouldn't take 40 years to walk across
it's three generations but what happens
is that in the aftermath of the collapse
of a tyrannical belief system well the
Tyranny disappears but then you're lost
and it's not obvious at all that being
lost is preferable to being in the
Tyranny that's why people will develop
Nostalgia for the Tyranny it's also why
people won't let go of their beliefs
it's like imagine you stubbornly stick
to a counterproductive pattern of
behavior and you even know it's
counterproductive but you won't let it
go think well why would you be so damn
Daft not to let go of something that you
know is hurting you and the answer is
well
better the devil you know than the
desert you don't right it's a really big
problem and in The Exodus story there's
an emphasis it's like it might the
desert period it might extend past your
lifetime
oh right right well you know with the
whole if a whole tyrannical Society
collapses yeah there's no reason to
assume that the society is going to
regenerate within the span of your life
you know you might just be the cohort
that's cast into the desert that
happened in Russia in the Soviet Union
after collapse so if you were like 45 or
older in 1989
or 50 let's say you're just screwed
right because everything that you knew
collapsed and you're 50 you know you're
near retirement you're going to start
again
well
your your three-fifths done or
four-fifths done there's no lots of
people can't start again or won't even
if they're 30. hey guys did you know
that Dad did Research into hangover
curious in his 20s while he was at
Miguel he told me that after I told him
I'd found a supplement that drastically
improves hangovers and gave it out to
his friends at one of his parties he
doesn't drink at all anymore I do on
occasion however after party is my pure
high dose filler-free supplement
available at fullerhealth.com it's
composed of high dose dihydramyriston
which is incredibly effective in
breaking down the toxic byproduct of
alcohol called acetaldehyde acetaldehyde
is what poisons you and causes organ and
brain damage and hangovers when you
drink there are a ton of peer-reviewed
Articles available at fullerhealth.com
that I've linked for the Nerds out there
if you want to read up on the extract
we're using it's very interesting I
drink Vodka sodas on occasion not often
but I do sometimes and I can't afford to
be useless the next day I hate it I
figure this reduces my my hangover bar
about 75 percent it's a really clean
supplement it reduces jitteriness with a
hangover and leaves you feeling calm and
clearer reduces nausea headaches Etc
there's a 30 day money back guarantee so
no risk and you take three pills before
bed after drinking and two in the
morning there's also evidence that if
you take it before drinking you'll
actually drink less there are 24
servings in this massive bottle which
adds up to about two dollars and fifty
cents per avoided hangover we made this
as pure and healthy as possible with
third-party testing and Amber gloss
bottle metal Lids Etc because of my
autoimmune issues and reactions to
excipients and fillers and pills which
is crazy but if you drink drink wisely
save your body and brain as much as you
can if you choose to poison it with
alcohol and you can use code MP for 15
off we're going to be rolling out more
supplements soon so you can sign up to
be notified at fullerhealth.com which is
linked in the comments MP for 15 off and
I hope you enjoy the rest of this
episode okay so from my experience of
like belief systems falling and I think
my first belief system that fell was
like full-blown trust in the medical
system because of what happened to me
and when that fell I've talked about
this a bit
it impacted almost every part of my life
where I was like I believed that you
know I believe that that was how I was
going to get better it didn't make me
better something else outside of that
got me better which is the diet that
we're on which it was ridiculous
exploratory capacity yes for sure
um but I think that was the first belief
system that fell and then I lost trust
in everything yeah like if that was
wrong is the government wrong what else
is wrong this is something that
Nietzsche pointed out with regards to
the psychological consequences of of
European colonialism on Europe
so he said okay imagine Europe is uh
Christendom
all things considered when the European
expansion started okay now the Europeans
go out into the world
and there's some arguments within
Christendom about which branch of
Christianity should rule you know when
there's doubters yeah but basically as
far as the Europeans were concerned the
cosmos was structured according to
judeo-christian precepts it was just the
Assumption Network okay so now the
Europeans go out in the world and they
find out that there's a lot of different
belief systems equally well developed or
arguably equally well developed
apparently predicated on different
axiomatic systems okay so now that
brings up doubt so the doubt is well you
know the uh Japanese Chinese they seem
to be doing pretty well and they're not
or better even in some regards I think
you could argue that when the Europeans
hit Japan that the Japanese had obtained
a higher level of of sophisticated
civilization in many ways they're
certainly well advanced in the hygienic
front for example and so that's the
first doubt the first doubt is oh oh
there's a bunch of belief systems
but then Nietzsche pointed out but then
there's a secondary doubt which is once
you realize that any that uh that a
belief system per se especially a
relatively core one can collapse that
raises not only the Specter of which
belief system is correct
but another Specter which is well what
makes you think any belief system is
justifiable yeah yeah right and that's
the nihilist trap it's like well
everything is meaningless right and you
know and that's a hard trap to get out
of and we're certainly still Niche new
that after the death of God which was
something he regarded as really the
ultimate catastrophe the ultimate murder
that two things were most likely to
happen one would be a descent into a
kind of counterproductive nihilism the
loss of all values that's how he
construed it and all the psychological
disorientation that goes along with that
and the other would be a radical turn
towards a replacement totalitarian
certainty which he believed and said
would likely come from the radical left
in the form of something approximating
communism he nailed that like 1850
stunning and Dostoevsky knew exactly the
same thing they both got it exactly
right and so and that is exactly what
happened
so yeah so
and then there's another way of thinking
about it too is that
you look at the world through a
hierarchy of a
presuppositions of axioms yeah so like
if you're married one of the axioms is
and this would be the definition of
marriage one of the axioms of marriage
is likely Trust on the interpersonal
communication front like you have to you
have to assume that your partner is
revealing to you what they are and then
sexual Fidelity would be the other and
those are obviously integrally
Associated but those are the two you
could argue those are the two funded
fundamental pillars Okay so
everything else in the marriage and that
would be your self-conception your
conception of your future the past your
partner other people all of them depend
on the Integrity of those axioms and so
if any either of those axioms are uh
um challenged so your partner lies to
you in some fundamental way or betrays
you on the sexual front the whole
edifice tumbles down yeah right and
that's okay and so what happens
technically there is that edifice gives
you security because things are defined
and so they're not all the look if you
can't trust someone you don't know who
the hell they are right and when you're
facing someone and you don't know who
they are they could be anyone like they
could be Mother Teresa or Ted Bundy
right that's a big range okay so someone
you can't trust is a nightmare of
entropy and the reason they're a
nightmare of entropy is because you
don't know which direction to take like
they're a multitude of potent they're an
infinite multitude of potential
directions okay you the systems within
you that signal anxiety signal the
emergence of that multitude of Pathways
it's like you know you you I've seen
this in interviews I've out it's like
you know I thought they were good faith
interviews and then I discovered that I
was talking that yeah no kidding it's
like oh I see you're not who you claim
to be and whatever's happening here
isn't what I thought what's going on and
the answer is God only knows right so
anxiety signals that anxiety comes up
and says you thought you were here
in the Walled Garden
but it turns out that you're in chaos
and then
because you don't know how difficult it
will get be to get out of the chaos and
re-establish order your brain says
warning warning multiple Pathways ahead
multiple indeterminate Pathways ahead
that equates to incalculable expense of
energy and time probable right and so
you get anxious that's and that's what
freezes you it's you don't know which
direction to go
you turn to Stone so when when the when
the mythological hero faces the the
terrible chaotic famine let's say with
the head of snakes it's a it's a
predator
he freezes and the reason for that is
well if you don't know what direction to
go
how about you don't move
right that's anxiety it's a signal of
emergent entropy an entropy can tear you
apart right it's complete disorder so
okay so I have like four or five
questions from that whole thing that
just happened but I think I think the
first one
what do people do if something they
fundamentally believed changes and
they're left in this state of what's
even stable in my life like where do you
start when yeah okay Frozen Okay so back
to the Book of Exodus this is so cool
Jonathan pasjo explained this to to all
of us and like I don't think any of us
ever recovered after he explained it
because it's so bloody brilliant so the
Israelites are out in the desert right
they're lost and they have the habits of
slaves so they don't know what they're
doing and they're all and they're
whining about having the Tyranny back
and they're bitching about Moses and
they're worshiping like golden calves
and they're fighting with each other
it's just like chaos so they don't know
where to go and so God Appears to them
and God appears as a pillar of light at
night so it's a fire and a pillar of
Darkness during the day and so pajo said
that's the same thing as the Taoist yin
and yang it's the same idea so what does
it mean well the Taoist in the Taoist
world view reality itself so that's
experiential reality is made out of the
balance between Chaos and Order okay now
order is where you are when things are
going the way you want them to go that's
Order and Chaos is where you don't know
what the hell is going on so chaos is
also a possibility right the future is
chaos and Novelty is chaos now in the
Taoist worldview the little serpent
because it's a serpent that that's the
white serpent there had had has a black
dot in it it's because order can turn
into chaos at the drop of a half yeah
and the black serpent has a white dot in
it because chaos can reveal a new order
and that's the interplay of reality the
interplay between the unknown and the
known now
when you're
Guided by that which grips your interest
optimally right so you're attentive
because you're interested in something
you're focused on what it means is that
Chaos and Order are balanced for you in
a way that doesn't flood you too much so
you're not too terrified but that isn't
so predictable that nothing no
transformation is taking place in front
of now you might think well what I want
to be is stable
and the answer that's wrong you don't
want to be stable you want to be stable
and improving right okay so
something will back into you as
compelling and interesting if it's
exactly on the frontier between Chaos
and Order that will move your
development forward right and when that
happens you're engaged that's the
instinctive meaning that's how God
manifests himself to the Israelites in
the desert it's that the thing that
grips your attention it's like this the
snitch that that Harry Potter chases
that wins the game yeah you know that's
the thing that dances and grabs your
attention and so you could think of God
in the story of Exodus is that which
calls to you and you see a precursor of
that in Exodus because Moses leaves it
Egypt at one point he kills a
um an Egyptian who has beaten up an
Israelite and he kills them and then the
word gets around and he's afraid the
Pharaoh is going to kill him so he
leaves and he goes to this land
um midi I think it's media his
father-in-law is a midianite priest so I
think it's media but but
the people who live there are midi at
nights anyways he marries one of the
priest's daughters and he settles into
their household and like he's very
valued there because he rescued the
girls including the one he married from
these like thugs at a well and they're
pretty happy with Moses and now he's a
shepherd and he's and a Shepherd is a
guide and leader right that's what a
Shepherd does and the Shepherd protects
the weak because that's also what a
Shepherd does and remember in the Middle
East at this time there's lions and
wolves and like you're you're not some
trivial dude if you're a Shepherd
because you're out there alone and then
where there's predators and you're you
know taking care of the vulnerable so
that's that's the lead yeah yeah that's
the leader right that's why the shepherd
is a leader figure in in the Old
Testament you have a rod that you move
the sheep with and fight off the
Predators and that's Moses and he's
having a perfectly fine time he doesn't
want to go back to Egypt and he goes
it's actually happens near Mount Sinai
he encounters a burning bush and so
Moses is going about his business and
all of a sudden something attracts his
attention
and he and he decides to go off his path
right so the path of normality to attend
to this thing that captures his interest
and it's not like a burning Forest it's
just something that Glitters right it's
a call
and so Moses goes to investigate and as
he approaches it he realizes that it's a
burning bush and so what does that mean
well a tree is the symbol of life like
the tree of life right the tree is a
symbol of life because well trees are
alive obviously but that branching
complexity is sort of emblematic of life
and a burning tree is being and becoming
at the same time because fire is
transformation and so the burning bush
is a symbol of being and becoming
simultaneously right and so Moses
investigates this and as he investigates
it more deeply here's a voice and the
voice says you're starting to tread on
sacred ground
and so he takes off his shoes and
continues to investigate and that's when
God himself reveals himself to Moses and
then really transforms him into a
revelatory leader and the idea there is
it's such an amazing idea and I think
it's absolutely right is that you know
you're going to be walking down your
pathway in life and maybe you're
perfectly content and something is going
to glitter and gleam in the in the
periphery capture your interest right
and it's partly you because it's you
that's interesting interested but it's
partly the world calling to you because
you don't get to say what makes you
interested right it sort of happens to
you yeah it's a synchronicity like it's
a place where the narrative and the
objective touch and so if you decide to
go off your pathway and investigate what
interests you
and you investigated enough you go
deeper and deeper and deeper and if you
go deep enough you get on sacred ground
and that's where you're getting so deep
that you're starting to study that which
everything depends on and then if you
continue to study you'll get right to
the bottom of things itself that's Moses
encounter with the Divine and if you do
that you will be a leader right and so
that's and so you say well what guides
you when you're lost well the
manifestation of intrinsic meaning
guides you when you're lost you can hear
that in music like music plays out the
balance between Chaos and Order properly
it sort of tells you what is
intrinsically meaningful and and uh and
and necessary and beautiful and true all
of that and so and it's so cool because
it works out neurologically really like
it is the case that you advance
developmentally on the edge of chaos
right because you have to push yourself
to advance yeah that's what you do when
you play like if you're playing
one-on-one basketball with someone you
don't want to be six foot four and play
with your like four foot two nephew and
just stomp them to death and you think
well why not because you could beat the
little bastard non-stop it's like I'm
the Victor you don't want that right you
want to find someone who can push you
maybe you want to play with someone
who's slightly better than you now why
because it's harder to win and the
answer is well the win means that you're
developing that's the meta win and you
you obtain the meta win on the border of
chaos and that's all the place where the
hero operates and that's where you find
the dragon and all of that it's exactly
the same thing and meaning the Instinct
of meaning signifies that developmental
Edge and the the constant mythological
insistence is that God is to be found at
the core of what makes itself manifest
as meaning and that's a definition you
know and say well people think about
God it's like
got it the belief in God is Not
adherence to a set of semantic
propositions that's just not how it
works it's not like it's not like
reading a set of descriptors and saying
uh you know I I concur it's not that at
all it's being Guided by well it's by
Guided by the spirit of truth that's one
way of thinking about it Guided by the
spirit of Adventure that's another way
of thinking about it
and it's faith in meaning it's faith in
truth those aren't propositional ideas
and they're they they fit the neurology
perfectly because the Instinct of
meaning manifests itself on the edge of
development that's how your brain's set
up
so if you're floating around in chaos
because one of your belief systems
failed whether that's your job or your
belief in the medical system or your
relationship or something like that
your suggestion is
wait for something meaningful to appear
because it'll appear or watch like one
of the things you do
pressed if you're a behavioral therapist
you just say okay
let's have you track your mood for the
next two weeks like you're gonna think
because you're depressed it's like how
do you feel two out of ten win always
it's like no not always if you track
your mood you'll find that even if
you're severely depressed you'll vary
say between zero and four out of ten
okay so now it might be that you find
this is very common you find that even
though you don't want to see your
friends
if you're with them you're at four okay
and and then maybe there'll be some
other things if I listen to music if I'm
painting if I'm working out if I'm
building uh you know a shelf or whatever
there'll be different things that people
find compelling
um my mood lifts and here's some other
things I'm doing where I'm at zero yeah
okay let's start doing fewer of the zero
things and more of the four things and
see how far we can go and then maybe you
practice that for a month and now you're
doing some six out of ten things like
they'll be
there'll be domains of your life that
make themselves manifest as more able to
chase away the darkness and you need to
discover what those are and you have to
be humble which is you don't know
because what do you know about yourself
the things that you find meaningful that
make themselves manifest as meaningful
you might not want to even admit like
maybe you have a woman who's hell-bent
on her career for ideological reasons
but if you get her to track her mood
she's far happier when she's with her
kids or the reverse right you might have
a woman who
um would like to believe that having her
children is enough but if you track her
mood you find that if she isn't out
pursuing her career thirty percent of
the time she's devastated and it's it's
an empirical you call this in behavioral
therapy you call this collaborative
empiricism and so the idea is well I
don't know who the hell you are and
neither do you so how about we watch we
watch and that's humility it's right
like I don't know I don't know and you
have to be brought to your knees to
watch that seriously well so then you
can find and then you know there's a
reliable pattern to the things that make
your life meaningful
so and this is one of the things I've
talked to my audiences a lot about is
that
there are so
you might say well I want to be happy
and people say that all the time and
they don't even know what the hell they
mean when they say that what they
actually mean is that they don't want to
suffer too much yeah but but they don't
but they don't say I don't I don't want
to be unhappy they say I want to be
happy but happiness is incentive reward
and it only occurs sporadically when
you're pursuing a goal and happiness has
its dangers too because it makes you
impulsive and when people say they want
to be happy they actually don't know
what they mean and what they really mean
what they really mean is something like
I want to have a meaning that will
sustain me even through catastrophe
and that's not happiness because when
you're in the catastrophe which you will
be or maybe always are you're not going
to be happy
okay so what do people where do people
find meaning and my
conclusion fundamentally it's not mine
this is the this fundamental Axiom of
Western Civilization as you find true
meaning in voluntary self-sacrifice
right so it's like you know you you have
a great relationship with your kids
you're a mother well it means you've
given up yourself to a large degree to
Foster that relationship same with your
relationship with your partner like it's
not self-monitored them but it's in that
responsible
shouldering of the virtues of the
relationship that the meaning arises and
the most reliable source of meaning is
responsible responsible self-sacrificial
conduct and so here's something very
cool I went to the Church of the Holy
Sepulcher with Jonathan pajo it's in
Jerusalem and it was the first church
now it's hypothetically situated on the
place where Christ hung himself on the
cross it was hung on the cross and so
what does that mean well at minimum
psychologically it means that the
community is founded on the principle of
voluntary self-sacrifice
that's what it means and so you have the
cross at the center of the church and
that's the place that's the place of the
altar that's the place of sacrificial
offering then you have the church
surrounding that then you have the town
surrounding that and then the community
itself and this was the pattern for
European towns for centuries the states
surrounding that but the thing at the
middle was responsible voluntary
self-sacrifice towards a higher good
right and it took people thousands of
years to delineate out that Vision you
know you see it developing through the
Old Testament but it's fully realized in
many ways in the New Testament with the
idea that you have to bear the weight of
death
voluntarily and also the weight of Hell
of malevolence you have to you have to
take that on to yourself and in doing so
you transcend it in doing so you also
act out the foundation of community
itself and of course that's true because
if I'm going to be in a community
I have to give up myself like my
short-term merely me focused self
obviously that's the definition of
community you know if it's me first
always
there's no community
so to me these things they've started to
become almost truisms it's like well
obviously Community the stable
healthy Community is predicated on
voluntary self-sacrifice like well what
how else could it be no sacrifice no
that's not going to get you anywhere the
sacrifice of other people well that's a
little convenient for you plus the other
people don't exactly appreciate it and
so you know if you're a good mother
there's so much easier that way well
right it is in the short term but that's
the other thing it's actually not easier
so Psychopaths do that all the time they
sacrifice other people to their own
whims at the drop of a hat so what
happens to Psychopaths well they end up
in prison
they fail to learn from experience they
have to wander from town to town like
they end up in hell it doesn't work
because people catch on you know usually
and then then there's hell to pay like
literally literally so
there isn't an alternative and you know
you might think well who the hell wants
the path of voluntary self-sacrifice
like fair enough you know with the cross
and hell it's doesn't exactly sound like
a picnic but if you know that the
alternative is hell
then you think well you know yeah
it also
at least from what I've gone through it
seems to get easier like the first time
it happens to you or a belief system
Falls and you're in chaos it's pretty
horrible for quite a while
but then you kind of get used to it
that's what I found anyway so then the
next thing that happens well maybe it's
worse than the first thing that happens
but then each dramatic thing that
happens after that it's like oh you know
what I already did this one and I
survived and then I think you can take
on more risks well then you also have a
different conception of what you are
because yeah here here's conception one
I am what I believe
okay that's great as long as it's
working but as soon as your belief
collapses well then who are you and then
the next conclusion is I'm whatever is
left over when my belief system
collapses and that's the depressive
nihilistic State it's like well you know
everything's up in the air and life is
fundamentally misery and I'm this
disoriented thing and that's the
essential nature of being you know
stable State collapse into chaos I'm the
stable State nope I'm chaos nope well
then order re-emerges from chaos and now
you think well I'm the New Order
and that that's the fervor of a convert
but then it collapses and then you do
that five times and you think oh I see
I'm the thing that does this right
that's right that's right that's
Sisyphus it's the voluntary acceptance
of the fate of Sisyphus you're the thing
that's rolling the stone up the mountain
then it rolls back down but it's a
different Mountain each time and maybe
each Peak is higher right and so then
you're the thing that transforms that's
why in the judeo-christian ethos in the
judeo-christian
narrative World your soul is identified
with the dying and resurrecting savior
because that's you're the thing that
goes through this process of
purification by repeated deaths and
rebirths right and so then you're the
thing that withstands the repeated
deaths and rebirths in the favor of the
emergence of a higher higher order you
know and and the pathway of that that's
Jacob's Ladder that's the pathway to
Paradise that's the hero's path that's
why Jung said that Christ was a symbol
of the self because that core self isn't
what you believe and it's not the
catastrophe that ensues when belief
disintegrates it's the process by which
you're honed in fire by repeatedly
encountering you know what salutary and
transforming and then if you identify
with that the more you identify with
that the more you can say
Bring It On yeah right and the ultimate
extent of that is probably something
like embracing your enemy and you think
well how the hell can I do that it's
like
here's a hypothesis
the more you could embrace the worst
enemy the more radically you could
transform for the better
right because the worst enemy is going
to bring everything that could possibly
take you out against you worst enemy in
an idea way or as a person either way
either way whatever knocks you off your
feet
yeah you think well something's coming
to knock me off my feet you might think
well
maybe maybe I could use what knocks me
off my feet to shed what's most useless
about me
and you know and we've seen this we've
seen this in our family you know
practically speaking because one of the
things we did learn was that just
because the attack looked like a
catastrophe
doesn't mean that it isn't the best
thing that could have possibly happened
even though you might not see that for
like two years
yeah right right and then of course it
depends on how you dance with it too you
know I mean when we when I was one of
the most shocking things that happened
to me when I was still ill was to be
portrayed in the Marvel series as Red
Skull right I mean it just knocked me
off my feet I couldn't believe it it was
so
insanely surreal and over the top and we
didn't know what the hell to do about
that hilarious also hilarious well
I thought you might have taken a little
bit of time to get there
well by the way yeah and I was sick too
by that time it had happened enough so
that it wasn't yeah but it did it really
literally when when I first saw it it I
literally I almost fell over it shook me
like it shook me so badly because I just
couldn't believe it was happening but
then we turned it into a joke really and
put a you know we made that Lobster
symbol some check cash it was a check
kid right made that Lobster out of the
Hydra image we made that tell the truth
and make your band the evil logo and
then ran a charity Venture for well for
about a year I think yeah yeah and so
that worked you know and that's a weird
thing because that worked out real well
and that that was an interest really
interesting example because it was it
was as profound a reputational blow in
some ways as could be mustard right it's
like to be pilloried as the Nazi is one
thing but like to be pilloried as the
source of all the magical source of all
Nazis that's a whole different level of
conceptualization and you think well you
know how could that be turned to
something good and that's a complicated
question but that doesn't mean it
couldn't be
so did you know Elvis's manager
um had all the I hate Elvis merch
that's what you do yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah well that was something I
joked about early you know one of the
first time I went on Joe Rogan I made
this you know horrible joke that I'd
figured out how to monetize social
justice Warriors and you know all the
people who think that I'm an evil
capitalist thought which I am
thought well there's just evidence that
he's an evil capitalist but it was also
a joke but it was also true it's like
okay like you guys you hate capitalism
and so you're going to use your woke
nonsense to go after people's reputation
it's like what's the funniest thing that
can be done with that and the clearly
the funniest thing to do with that is to
monetize it and so we've done that a lot
so the last time I was in Berlin we
accidentally rented a theater that was
right in the middle of the Communist
district and all the Communists thought
that was just a provocation and but it
wasn't it was just ignorance and we
didn't know that that was like communist
Central and yeah they had that area in
Berlin right right right you know so so
silly us but they did and so we got a
couple hundred protesters which was the
best the protesters had mustard on our
last tour because usually was like six
bedraggled individuals you know with
their signs protesting something they
didn't even purport to understand it you
know after a Big Show in the Press about
how there would be thousands of them
yeah and so but Berlin they managed a
pretty decent uh contingent but the
police there pretty used to handling
them and it's like a little dance they
all know how to do it so we went out and
filmed them and then use that as a promo
for the rest of the tour because it's
like what else are you gonna do about it
you know it's
you might as well do something comical
and and hypothetically productive and
satirical at the same time and so I want
credit for that yeah that was I think
that was your uh well I think the I
don't remember how much of the Red Skull
charity Venture was also that was a
collaborative venture between the two of
us did you find the check kid yeah on
Twitter yeah right yeah yeah so he was
he was great yeah yeah well you know we
always had a relationship well and this
was true in our household in general
like there was always
like to satire and play we had to Yeah
well yeah there's that too but but it
wasn't just you know the friends that I
had and you know this the friends that I
had when I was a kid you've met a lot of
them all we ever did was joke
it was just continual joking the
friendships I had for almost all my life
where it's all competitive humor and so
we did the same thing in our household
your mom figured you out about six years
ago it took her a long time and said I
don't know what to make Michaela said
everything Michaela says is a joke it's
like really it's like yes yes just
listen and then your mom figured that
out she thought oh what you know she
kind of knew it wasn't like she was
completely out of the loop on that front
hang on 17. it was even worse for your
mom because she realized that you know
she had no idea how much like you she is
text Michaela you know she's kind of
rough it's like Tammy you know she's
exactly like you she's no I'm not really
like that's like
yeah you're exactly like that you're
exactly like that
actually I think once she finally really
swallowed that she thought that was
pretty good compliment to All Things
Considered Ah that's nice yeah yeah
okay let's switch directions hey
everyone as you may know recently I got
quite ill from living in a house with
mold behind the drywall and in the hvacs
which is why I had to pause the podcast
for like six months and recover my brain
but saunting has been something that's
been hugely beneficial for recovering
from that I've been saunting for years
to reduce symptoms of autoimmunity and
anxiety depression
Etc and if I eat something wrong that
gives me an autoimmune flare-up I sauna
there's so much evidence that is good
for Health and Longevity by helping your
body detox faster amongst other benefits
Bond charge is a holistic Wellness brand
that has products ranging from Blue
Light glasses to red light therapy all
their stuff is good but their sauna
blanket is my favorite it works by
helping you detox and sweat it raises
your heart rate like exercise so it
burns calories it's super easy to set up
and clean and you can travel with it
which is huge for me seems to improve my
mood by about 30 after use which is
significant free shipping easy returns
and exchanges 30-day trial 12 months
warranty all that good stuff you can go
to boncharge.com MP and use coupon code
MP to save 15 that's
b-o-n-c-h-a-r-g-e.com slash MP and use
code MP to save 15 uh but that was
fascinating I actually kept up with that
whole thing which is which is great but
I think that's also from years of
experience of
trauma and then getting through it and
then and now I've realized when bad
things happen
and I have this belief that's like
firmly ingrained in me that when my life
was going really well and then suddenly
oh everything's upside down again it's a
period of time
and I'm going to end up in a better
place on the other side and it is going
to end and I believe that so when bad
things happen now I go oh well I hope
this isn't a year and a half of bad
things but I'm sure there's something
here that I need to learn unfortunately
which is a better state of being than
I'm in the middle of a catastrophe and
it's never going to go away and this is
my life forever yeah which I don't
believe anymore yes the Book of Job
outlines that right because it's a
terrible book oh yeah because God makes
a bet with Satan actually the reverse
yeah and Satan you know job's a good guy
yeah Satan says yeah yeah I bet I can
take him out and God says no I don't
think you can he's a good guy I don't
think do your worst yeah you know do
your worst have Adam man and you know
people read that the like the kind of
shallow atheist materialist types read
that they think God's so reprehensible
it's like have you lived
you know you don't think there's
anything reprehensible about life you
don't think like horrible unfair things
are going to be hurled your way and that
that has to be incorporated into your
idea of the absolute it's like
definitely that's coming so like how
about you don't be so naive you know on
the one hand the critics of those
stories say well you know religion is a
defense against death anxiety and you
think okay yeah what about the story of
Job
like the god in there isn't isn't
promising as believer's Everlasting
Bliss it's like I'll take you out
earthquakes storms and Satan himself I'm
coming at you you better get ready
there's no whitewashing that and job's
response is no matter what is thrown out
no matter what it is he maintains faith
right and that's that's not blind
stupidity that's not
superstitious childlike Faith that's
that's toughness it's like no I can
handle this I don't care what it is
there's something that I can allow Ally
myself with
like a principle the principle of Truth
maybe there's something I can Ally
myself with that will carry me through
this right and if you don't have that
then it just takes you out so you need
to have that well you could otherwise
you could just be miserable and then
also be in hell and right right and then
that can last for your whole life yeah
and maybe your children's life and yeah
yeah those are the Alternatives yeah
okay let's um let's discuss what we're
doing with Peterson Academy hey why
don't you introduce it
okay I will so uh I think most people
know that you did a personality course a
number of years ago
which was wildly successful
I thought it was great
and
um I thought first of all we should make
more of those made a bunch of money and
I'm
you know motivated by that made a bunch
of money it also taught people it was a
cool way of learning uh so I thought
well we should do that and then I
thought we could do that for other
people
and so that's kind of how the idea came
up and then you have been talking about
some sort of online university for years
and years and so that kind of I think
Amalgamated into well I knew I started
learning you know when I started putting
my lectures out on YouTube I thought
well
obviously you know what and I also
thought
why wouldn't it be good to provide
everybody at least in principle with
access to the best lectures yeah you
know like because now we can in the
barrier technological barrier to that is
being blown apart and you know before
you needed 500 lectures on personality
let's say distributed across the world
and most of them you know 95 of them
weren't particularly good but now in
principle you could gather the best
lectures from all over the world and and
then also
give them free reign to say what they
want take it out of the idiot
bureaucratic restrictions that the
universities apply and bring it to
everyone and so I started experimenting
with that on YouTube and that became
wildly popular with people and yeah and
so then we started doing that with all
sorts of other lectures whenever I
interviewed someone or gathered someone
up I thought really knew what they were
talking about we've been recording them
how many courses have we recorded now we
have almost 20. we're gonna have more on
launch our plan is to launch in November
I think we'll probably do a soft launch
so there's going to be a certain number
of available you know memberships that
will sell we're aiming for about forty
dollars a month so that it's accessible
to everybody and it'll give people
access to the entire platform so they
won't have to pay per course there's a
social media element built in so people
will have profiles they'll be able to DM
each other they'll be able to post
they'll be able to form study groups uh
we're hoping to include location if you
want to turn location on so people can
actually meet up in person if they want
to study together and the courses look
so good and the nice thing about filming
courses is that they can be continually
updated so we have the best cameras we
could get so like Netflix quality
cameras and we can just continually
update the courses and so far we haven't
shot a course that I was like yeah maybe
we put this in the in the back and don't
show it to very many people so far
everything's been really good oh and
then our plan so we were trying to
figure out this whole accreditation
process which is a complete nightmare
because all the accreditation
like completely woke and the entire
University system is kind of structured
strangely and they force you to take
courses that aren't really applicable to
your degree it takes a certain number of
time it takes a certain number of years
so you can't really combine all your
studying in quickly the entire thing
just bothered me when I went to
University I didn't think it was I
didn't want to take certain courses that
I was forced to take for a degree that
had nothing to do with it made no sense
so we're starting with a general
education degree which I think could be
applicable to anybody yeah so let me
expand on that yeah so for people who
are watching and listening you know you
might think well why should you have a
why should you be generally educated so
that would be something like why would
you take a Bachelor of Arts and there's
two answers to that one is well do you
want to learn to communicate and think
or not yeah so let's walk through that
why do you think
so you can think things through before
you act them out so you don't end up in
hell that's why so that's why you think
you think so that your stupid thoughts
can die instead of you that's why you
think and that's technically and
biologically why you think so like learn
to think and you're probably mostly
going to think in words at the more
sophisticated level
although you can also think in images so
you should be exposed to the greatest
images and the greatest words so that
you can craft your tools and prepare and
then well why should you communicate and
the answer is
well like do you want to have some
customers because you're going to have
to talk to them you're going to
formulate some contracts are you going
to convince people to come along with
you or invite them it's like so you
better be able to communicate and so
that's on the process front you should
know how to think
and you should know how to communicate
because otherwise you're going to be a
useless resentful bitter pointless
counterproductive lump and that's not a
good strategy but then there's a second
element to it which is that as you move
yourself up the ladder of accomplishment
let's say you'll increasingly encounter
people who know things and you know yeah
if you get to the upper echelons of any
uh of any hierarchy you'll start
encountering people who know a lot about
almost everything and so if you're
stupid and you don't know anything about
anything then like they're just going to
look at you and listen to you for like
two seconds and think well I don't know
where this clunk came from but you know
he's not come along for the ride and so
you should know something about music
and art and literature and history and
and Science and of all the different
Sciences you need to be enculturated
because
well so that you can play with
sophisticated people and you could play
a sophisticated and productive game but
also so that you've informed yourself
with the greatest ideas of History so
that whatever problem you're tackling
you're going to have tools to tackle it
with and so that's why you need to be
generally educated and that's why we're
putting together this this Corpus of
lectures we're hoping that once we get
it well developed you'll be able to take
all these courses and then you know you
won't be a complete embarrassment to
yourself and that you know
hypothetically that'll be useful and so
on on the social front so one of the
things that we've come to realize as
we've been thinking through the
university issue is that you know
because you might say well why why will
people pay seventy five thousand dollars
a year for a degree and part of the
answer to that is well they leave their
cotery of high school friends you know
it's kind of random and they get to do a
personality transformation to grow up
and to find a new group of peers but and
that's very important to find a new
group of parents man that's worth
something and some of those peers might
be the great figures of history but they
also might get a chance to find their
mate you know and so at a selective
University you bring people together who
are young people who are relatively
accomplished and so the pool from which
you have to choose your mate is all of a
sudden increased in quality dramatically
and so who knows what that's worth it's
worth a lot and so we realized as we've
been building this that
universities are whatever they are
they're much more than merely lectures
and accreditation that's probably 25
percent of what a university offers a
huge part of the rest of it is social
milieu and socialization and so that's
why we've been building out the the
social communication part of it and so
you're very excited about that part in
particular you've got more excited as
we've gone along and so what do you
think is good about the about the social
media side of the of the platform well
we took aspects from social media
platforms that already exist and thought
you know this kind of works you can
stick something like that on here and I
know that well Instagram's commonly used
for dating now so dming people seeing
what they look like and being able to
have a conversation is really important
and I think if you bring a bunch of
people onto a platform where you're all
trying to learn and improve yourselves
then the quality of people you're going
to meet there at least they're
interested in ideas they're gonna well
they're also on the same developmental
course as you yeah so I just wanted to
make sure like when we first started it
we had more of a
text-based communication and I wanted to
make sure we had an element of being
able to see what people looked like
because if you meet someone you want to
see what they look like and I think
that's more relevant I actually think
that's more relevant for women I'm not
sure if that's backed up but I know most
Instagram users are females so I think
women are more attracted to like what
what do I look like what do other people
look like so I wanted to put that on the
app whereas something like Reddit which
is mostly text based and it's it's
mostly male I didn't want to just stick
to that so we've combined that which I
think will also keep people on the
platform which is also one of the goals
yeah yeah well and we all we're also
trying to figure out how to bring people
together like physically because
you know it it's very useful what do you
do at University well you eat with
people you you know you share
Hospitality you party with people and
you know you can think about that as
extraneous entertainment but it's it's
not it might be the most important thing
you do actually and that's also true as
you conduct yourself in the professional
world you know I mean you make your
professional customers and your peers by
working together but the hospitality
element of it is incredibly important
because that's how you get to know
people outside of the narrow sphere of
yourself shared your shared interest
that's how you sort of decide whether or
not
you're well that you can trust each
other and whether you can play well
together you know and that's very
important if you want a long-term
relationship professionally or you know
or socially and so we need to be able to
duplicate that and that's going to take
something yeah but that'll take time
just because we'll need enough people on
the platform so that there will be
people on the platform in certain
people's areas so that I mean depends
how many people sign up for how fast
right that'll happen right right
um but I think initially we're going to
start with a smaller number of people
launch in November and then do a bigger
launch in in January and
I think people are going to love it yeah
well there's a comical element of this
too because yes like one of the things I
used to do with my graduate students
when they were doing a research project
is they'd come to me with the project
and I'd send them home for a weekend and
say look why don't you come back on
Monday and tell me how you would do this
if you could do it 10 times faster now
you might have to cut some Corners right
you might not be able to approach it
exactly the same way that you've decided
to but if you could make it 90 more
efficient it's going to be worth a
certain degree of sacrifice especially
if you can do that with no decrement
quality at least think it through you
know I had one student she was Bloody
brilliant she got like 99th percentile
on the verbal GRE after learning english
four years before that's right like
that's impossible and she did it she was
a real genius and she finished her first
draft of her master's degree in one
weekend yeah you know I told my students
like write a really bad first draft
because you can do that anyways you know
how can you do this 10 times faster and
one of the things we thought that would
be very funny especially because I'm
somewhat irritated at universities for a
variety of reasons was we tried we
thought what if we could make getting a
degree 95 percent less expensive because
that's a pretty funny Target it's like
we're going to undercut You by 95
percent and and offer a better quality
experience along the way at least in
terms of explicit learning and and you
know I think that we have a crack at
that and on the accreditation front so
we've been Banning this out a lot you
know I went and talked to some people
there are people that wanted to partner
with us you know mortar and brick
universities that in principle could
have helped us with the accreditation
process and we've been talking to people
in different political jurisdictions who
are interested in partnering with us
some in Canada and some in the U.S some
in Europe but our conclusion is being
especially after having good faith
discussions with them is that
the detrimental consequence in terms of
time and effort yeah and perversion of
the ultimate goal in terms of pursuing
accreditation might make it not
worthwhile
and so what we thought instead I think
this is a better solution is that we're
going to go directly to businesses like
you'll be able to take courses on our
site but it's not going to be that easy
to get the degree right it's going to be
rigorous and if you get a degree from
our Institution
you'll be tiered so people will know how
well you perform but the performance
criteria will be like intense and
reliable now the disadvantage to that is
going to be harder to get the degree the
advantage is that if you do get it
you're going to be far more marketable
once people know that the degree is a
valid signifier and so we're going to
talk to businesses which we can
definitely do and say look you know
um here's what our graduates will know
here's how we tested them they'll be
able to communicate this is the rigorous
process they went through you'll be damn
fortunate if we can provide you with a
list of people who've graduated and if
you had any sense you'll you know you'll
you'll uh you'll employ them
preferentially because we did the
rigorous screening work and I know how
to do the rigorous screening work
because I studied that for like 25 years
and I worked with a company in
California
that started like 5 000 small businesses
around the world we screen tens of
thousands of people we know how to
predict for managerial competence
administrative competence creative
competence and we really know how to do
that
and so our a degree from our University
will signify high-level
conscientiousness and general cognitive
ability and those are very valuable for
any employer with a clue so I think we
can just skip the connotation process
and go right to the employers and then
we've also been thinking
about
you know Ally our general education
approach with something like a
requirement for something maybe
approximating a Technical Training boot
camp so that people who come out you
know will also have one other layer of
marketable skill and teaching people how
to program
you know you need to be able to spin a
laptop around on your finger like Harlem
Globetrotter does with a basketball
because then you're you know 15 times
this deadly and so we haven't quite
worked out exactly how we're going to do
that but it it's all you know these boot
camps last what 10 weeks yeah if people
could get a general education degree so
that they could have a conversation with
competent people and not sound like a
and then they did some sort of
boot camp to hone exactly what the
skills they wanted in order to get a job
they'd be more educated than most people
who go to university oh yeah for sure
definitely so that's the goal yeah and
so in our our criteria for selecting
professors is well do you know what
you're talking about and are you
extremely interesting and that's good
criteria and uh then we tell the people
who come it's like
come offer the course that you could
offer if you offered the course that
would be exactly the course you would
want to offer and assume that you'll
have an audience of people who really
want that because we everybody records
in front of a live audience and we
select the audience very carefully it's
people who want to be in the audience to
listen to that topic and so we have
extremely enthusiastic professors and
extremely enthusiastic
audiences and the filming is very high
quality and the editing is high quality
and we've added all sorts of graphics
and oh there's more too so when you're
watching the video These are some
features I want to give them all away
but when you're watching the video
you'll be able to comment on the video
while you're watching it and it'll be
time stamped so if you go to the middle
of the video you can see what people are
talking about there you can also see the
entire transcript which is so helpful
because I actually have an easier time
just reading a transcript than I do
watching a video for whatever reason or
listening to a podcast so you get the
entire transcript which has been edited
you'll be able to highlight and annotate
the transcript so you can take notes and
then there's a section of the app for
that it's it's what I would have wanted
if I had taken online courses which I
did and they were terrible it's what I
would have wanted watching courses and
taking notes so most universities and
this is why they failed with these
massive online courses mostly is they
take a bad lecture and then film it
badly yeah right and it's like the
lecture itself isn't very exciting and
then you add like really low production
quality and bad audio it's like that
none of that's helpful and none of
that's adapted to the realities of the
digital communication age there's just
no reason to be stuck in that model and
so we'll see it's an exciting Venture
and we are also you know one of the
things we've done too this has been
really fun so when we did Exodus seminar
some of the people who came for the
Exodus seminar they were professors from
Cambridge mostly on the professorial
side they also recorded lectures for the
Peterson Academy and you know we treated
them really well and you'd think that
professors from Cambridge would be
treated with respect and paid reasonably
well and they're not treated with
respect by their institution and often
not by their students and they're not
paid well at all by any reasonable
standard and so when we brought them to
Miami we just treated them really well
and this is something to really know if
you're starting a business Enterprise
with people is that
the hospitality that you show people
pays off dramatically now you shouldn't
do that just for instrumental reasons
that's not the point I'm making the
point I'm making is that you know if you
treat the people that you work with
like you're happy that they're there and
maybe like you're really happy that
they're there and thank you very much
for coming and is there anything we can
do to make this easier for you and more
fun and uh you know we'll never let you
forget for a moment how thrilled we are
that you're participating believe me
that's a very rare attitude shown
towards professors even if they're
high-end professors at Great
institutions it was sort of like that
when I was at Harvard for a while
Harvard was damn good at treating its
senior professors in particular well but
man that vanished across time you just
ended up even if you were a great
professor and sometimes because you were
a great professor and there was jealousy
you just you just got treated like you
know just another employee and
um
and and that isn't really what I mean
just another Expendable card and that's
all also how students ended up being
treated to just another number you know
and that's just not helpful so we've
we've been very hospitable to the
professors that have come on board and
you know partly that's because we would
like them to come back but it isn't
instrumental in that sense we didn't get
together and say well we better treat
these people right so that they keep
producing content for us it was like no
we're really happy we're that we could
we could invite high quality people and
we're going to bloody well be sensible
enough to be appreciative of the fact
that they are high quality people and
that that's rare and we're going to
build that into everything we do and
lots of the people Greg for example
really commented you know and since a
lot of the people I've talked to
recently they've been very happy with
how they've been handled so to speak
when they've come down to Miami yeah
hopefully if we have any sense we we
won't let that disappear it's one of the
things I've really liked about working
with the daily wire plus crew too you
know is that we're in this expansion
phase of that Enterprise and everybody's
enthusiastic about new ideas and when
you have a new idea and you perform
there isn't a lot of backbiting jealousy
going on behind the scenes everybody's
happy to be on board and you know and
and positive about the expansive ideas
that's rare if you're in an in if you're
in an environment like that man that's
rare and well so far that's what's been
happening with Peterson Academy yeah
I've done what I did a course on
Nietzsche half of Beyond Good and Evil
yep I did a course on The Sermon on the
Mount yeah I really liked that word yeah
I did one on
maps of meeting one on maps of meeting
an updated maps of meaning
and shorter than the ones that I've done
online so these are all eight hour
courses because we figured that was
about the right length and uh one on
Piaget yeah yeah we've got a bunch
upcoming yeah yeah so I think that was
all of the main yeah well thank you for
the opportunity to run with Peterson
Academy
you have a good time
yeah why
well so most of my life especially since
I was about 23 because before that was
just a blur of
horror
after that was kind of a blur of horror
too but
um but most of my life I've probably
spent trying to fix problems and they
were problems that it wasn't like
something that kind of bothered me it
was like this is going to kill you right
like autoimmune disorder or something
which I think normally people would be
like well it's something I have and I
just have to live with and then I'm
gonna die but at some point for some
reason I was like no I'm gonna fix it
I don't know why
I think it's because I was worried I was
gonna die I was like well I better start
doing other things
um and so most of my life I've spent
working on problems that were generally
related to health that I needed to go
away in order to do things I actually
wanted this is probably the first time
other than the podcast I really like
podcasting and so that's been kind of my
separation from all the problems I'm
working on but this is the first time
I'm working on something bigger that is
something that I want to do and so this
is more like an opportunity than a
problem yeah which is really exciting so
that's
it's fun in a much less stressful way
because it's just oh look at all the
opportunity oh we could add this what
did you like most about it like you've
interacted with these professors you set
up a film crew you've set up a studio
like and and you set up the business
around that too and learned a lot about
business in the last five years oh yeah
I know way more about International
taxes than I want to or ever wanted to
uh I think the most fun part of Peterson
Academy was
figuring out what should be on the
actual platform I mean it's exciting
talking to professors and helping them
come up with courses that would be
interesting but I really like the idea
of building a platform that has a really
easy way for people to communicate and
learn and it's all there and every time
I'm going on a social media platform or
if I'm on some
video app or Netflix is pretty good but
like just apps I'm like why is this
loading slowly why are there pop-ups
here why do I have to press three times
to get where I want there's just I guess
UI things that really irk me and so it's
nice being able to design something
that's going oh no that's annoying we're
not going to have that that's no you're
not going to have in a good position to
do this
um
Michaela got involved in my businesses
you tell me if I've got the story right
because I was sick for a fair bit of
this but when things
blew up for our family that was in 2016
2017.
I started to tour things started to be
occurring on a much broader scale
financially and practically and Tammy
stepped in to help on the logistical
front and then you stepped in to help
while on the business front right you
didn't know much about business at that
point kind of kind of so yes and um
there were some people you were working
with and I did some research on like
rates you should be paid and thought you
were being underpaid so I said we should
fire these people so I fired a number of
people and hired other people you know
to help you
um so on that side I was involved in the
business mostly what I focused on until
really two years ago a year and a half
ago was social media yeah it was like
put them on Instagram you know make sure
videos are done properly post every day
like spread it around online so that was
my main focus for a number of years as
opposed to the business and that was
more a couple of years ago when our
business end fell apart and
it really fell apart
who said that they knew what to do on
the business front no idea but it's
saying what to do on the business and
being expensive right so like they're
expensive and they say they know what
they're doing right no if you can't
understand somebody you're working with
you shouldn't work with them it's not
that they know so much more than you
that you don't understand which is a
mistake I think that took me like two
years to figure out working with some
people when I was like I don't really
get it but I'm not a business person
maybe I just don't get it or a lawyer
yeah or a tax lawyer maybe I just don't
understand
and then eventually I was like no I
think it's this person and then it was
that person so don't make that yeah well
and on the Peterson Academy front I mean
because you you learn the so if you're
working in different social media
platforms every social media platform is
its own cultural ecosystem right and
then to function effectively in that
cultural ecosystem you have to
understand the customs of the natives
right so when when the Canadian
Broadcasting Corporation for example
started putting their stuff on YouTube
for which they have nothing but contempt
they'd put on like three minute Clips
with a three-minute ad at the beginning
that you couldn't Skip and then they'd
like disallow comments so they get like
you know
a hundred and maybe get 10 000 views
and you know then that just made them
more contemptuous but they didn't know
that
well nobody wants to watch the
three-minute ad to watch your
three-minute idiot video that and they
certainly want to be able to skip the ad
and you don't get to disallow comments
because that's not how YouTube works and
so you have to know the culture and then
not only do you have to know the culture
and not be contemptuous of it it's like
just all those Tick Tock users you know
you have to have some respect for it
yeah and then you have to stay on The
Cutting Edge because it's very
competitive and if you're not on The
Cutting Edge which moves all the time
then well people get bored of what
you're doing and you sink to the bottom
and so Michaela you've been operating in
how many different social media
platforms are we effectively operating
on well we're we're on the main ones
like you I mean you started YouTube
at the beginning of YouTube so like that
was you
um Twitter was probably you too but
Instagram and Facebook Twitter me
Twitter is definitely still you
um it's Instagram and Facebook I think I
made your Facebook in like 2013 before
any of this started and then Instagram
was more like 2017 or something and then
Tick Tock as well Tick Tock we've hired
people to make Tick Tock content it
works better if you're actually on there
filming yourself talking to your
audience and we're using Clips to be
more effective if we actually spent more
time talking to the audience on Tick
Tock but we also have like 10 000 things
going on so it's not a primary concern
but all the major ones right well and
the advantage for Peterson Academy is
that you know the social media platforms
well enough in principle by using them
constantly to know what features a good
social media platform is going to have
to have right and so that's the thing
too you know if you're I've started a
lot of businesses and worked with a lot
of people now and one of the things you
need to know if you're there's this idea
that the Harvard Business School came
out with a long time ago that you know
if you're a good manager whatever the
hell that is you can manage anything and
that's I think that's complete bloody
nonsense because my experience has been
I think people who manage and know
nothing and think that managing is a
thing think that but it's not true the
people I've watched who run their
businesses properly
and I would say my partner Daniel
Higgins is a good example of this is
like he knows absolutely everything
about 100 of the entire Business from
The like ones and zeros in the code all
the way up to the customer base like he
knows it and someone has to know it and
like you have to get in there and
grapple with the details in order to run
something properly if you start parsing
that off if there's no one who knows
that the whole thing is going to go
sideways and so you've been actually in
the trenches with the social media
systems for
six years right as they've risen up and
so you actually know them so yeah you
know and that's been very useful and we
never were contemptuous of all these
different social media platforms you
know because I saw this with my
professorial colleagues especially with
regards to journalists and you know
there's reasons to be contemptuous at
least of certain journalists because
journalism attracts more than its fair
share of narcissists but my colleagues
the journalists would phone me I'd
always talk to them and my colleagues
would talk to me about that and their
usual response was I don't really talk
to journalists I'd say well why not so
well they always get things wrong and I
think
I see so all the journalists get things
you say wrong
and so they're all wrong I thought well
maybe you're just not very good at
explaining yourself and you're not that
interesting it's like you know heaven
forbid that thought and so and I also
didn't ever treat journalists unless
they deserved it you know like they were
snakes although even sometimes though
they are
um most the time in mainstream media
most of the time yeah it's all
especially if they're British and female
and so
yeah yeah I don't know why those all go
together because the British journalists
they're quite the pack of hounds say and
then there's some real Specialists on
that front and and their whole career is
how can I trap you into saying something
utterly stupid once so I get to Pat
myself on the back and igrandize myself
what a job oh yeah vicious man vicious
anyways um
we learned that and I always thought and
this is partly from being a psychologist
you know uh same thing on the self-help
front if you're a behavioral
psychologist all the ones I knew they
give their clients self-help books all
the time because you know if you have a
client who's uh who's got problems with
anger there's some good self-help books
written on anger managements like why
not give them a book
you know and you can be contemptuous of
this just a self-help book it's like
well what the hell is the problem here
it's in intro level philosophy
and someone's taking time and effort to
read that seems like a good thing and
then also to try to make themselves
better you're going to be contemptuous
of that you know and one particularly
smart derives of horrible snake-like
journalists said that I was the stupid
person smart person that took me back
for a while you know and then I thought
ah you think that's an insult yeah
that's the sort of person you are it's
like oh no I'm making complex things
accessible to people who aren't
particularly educated that's called an
educator
so and I always felt on the journalist
front I always felt the same way it's
like well why the hell wouldn't you
communicate with this broaden audience
as possible and we brought that same
attitude to all these social media
platforms like you know you can make fun
of tick tock and maybe you should but at
least to some degree but you could
always figure out how it works and then
use it as a communication tool and we
have all these little tiny shorts of all
sorts of different lengths and
you know if you can say something in a
few sentences for 15 seconds that you
know 10 000 people are gonna learn
something from
what in the world is wrong with that
and so
well that's one of the advantages to not
having a derisive attitude towards
things
yeah if you have a derisive attitude
towards things too you're just going to
make less money oh this is just like
bluntly oh I can't do that that's below
me yeah okay yeah I'm not going to sell
out this is funny too you know there's
some of you out there thinking I
wouldn't sell out it's like yeah don't
be thinking you're going to get the
opportunity to you know it's like I
there's no shortage of failed artists
who blame that on failure to sell out
it's like it's not that easy to sell out
and it also presumes that there are
people who want what you're offering and
uh that's pretty goddamn unlikely and
you know there are cheap sellouts and
there are expert sellouts and if you're
an expert sellout what has happened is
that you've brought your ability to sell
and market and communicate to the same
level as your ability to create and
produce and that's all a plus not a
minus and so if you think there's an
integral competition between being
creative and being commercially
successful all that means is that you
haven't harnessed your creativity to
solving the problem problem of
productive communication there's nothing
about it that's moral you can pat
yourself on the back all you want for
not being an evil capitalist but it most
of the time it just means you don't know
what the hell you're doing and you want
to make that moral instead of facing the
consequences of your own ignorance so
pack I'm not an evil capitalist it's
like no you're you're poor and resentful
congratulations yeah I'm hoping my goal
with like this opportunity with Peterson
Academy other than to educate people and
to produce great content and to build
something that's fun to use and all that
is to make you more money than you've
made with this project why do you find
that interesting now look you've always
been I think I find it funny
so why do I find it funny yeah that idea
or that goal well but it's it's there's
two things okay you find it funny but
like one at one time I remember when
Michaela was I don't know how old she
was about seven I think something like
that I think it was just before you were
diagnosed with with uh with arthritis
six six six you we were living in this
little ratty apartment on the University
of Toronto campus and we we saw people
coming and going in front of the house
and we went downstairs and Michaela had
taken all of the books all of her kids
books out in the front yard and was
selling them
um and uh she didn't ask she just went
out there and sold all these books and
you know some school teacher would come
by and bought like 30 of them because it
was like all the Dr Seuss books and
everything there were tons of money now
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah poor business
decision yeah but it was it was it was
fun to watch and like we we didn't say
anything at all yeah I know it was time
well and I thought it was right it's
like you were done with those books and
you were trying to figure out what to do
with them and you had taken it on to
yourself to you know undertake this
entrepreneurial venture and I thought
that was really see this is another
example of not
if someone does something new that's
exploratory and good it's really easy to
punish it out of existence like if your
wife for example maybe your wife makes a
little detour in her style choices right
and she buys something new that's a
little different and you're thinking
well what would you might be thinking um
you might be thinking well what are
people going to think of me if my wife
goes out dressed like that it's like
that's a pretty dismal thought there
buddy or maybe you're afraid of her new
fashion choice or you don't want her to
become a new person because maybe she'd
wise up and get rid of you or you're
jealous because she's trying something
new and you're stuck in your idiot
Rutter God only knows what stupid
jealous thoughts are going through your
mind and so or maybe you actually don't
like the new thing that she's bought and
maybe it's not even that good and so you
know that's probably unlikely because
what makes you a fashion Maven compared
to your wife for example but you know so
she tries something new which is her
attempt to be a little more interesting
than she already is and maybe that's a
good thing because then you don't get
bored with your wife and she tries this
and she's not perfect at it so you kind
of insult her either by not paying
attention to it or by saying something
rude and then that's it like for the
rest of her life she wears the clothes
she bought in like 1975 and then you
think oh my wife she's really let
herself go and the answer is no I see
just turned into what you let her become
and so you see someone that's right man
it's brutal it's brutal to watch people
do that to each other it's horrible and
it really costs them I'm bored with my
partner it's like yeah well you probably
put them in a box Peter Peter in the
pumpkin shell right where you kept her
very well no no kidding sad so someone
will try something new and kind of
scares you and so you'll you know
either not reward them or interfere and
if it's a new thing for the person it's
really fragile and if you punish them
you can just obliterate you can train a
dog to starve itself to death by hitting
itself on the nose hitting it on the
nose with a newspaper when it approaches
its food dish
right so now I don't know who discovered
that but that's horrible well it was
part of the behavioral experiments on
behavioral modification you know but the
the point was is that if it's reward
seeking Behavior incentive reward
seeking Behavior it's really easy to
obliterate it with punishment even if
it's a fundamental motivational goal so
this situation with you when you were
selling these books like one tack would
have been did he ask
and the lesson there is well if you're
ever going to do something new you have
to ask you have to get permission that's
a stupid lesson to teach someone it's
like well are you getting a good price
for your books it's like she's she's six
you want her to be not only a capitalist
but to get it right the first time
that's your stupid Theory right so the
right response there is you know like
why'd you do this and you know good for
you for taking a risk and so but my
point was is that you had an interest in
money we could always bribe you when you
were a little kid like I think I
remember collecting special coins too I
remember I gave you guys
my money when we moved from Boston to
Toronto do you remember that I don't
remember that I was five well we were
having like money like we we didn't have
that we didn't have a lot of money no no
until recently yeah yeah because we
don't want Ford magazines yeah Mom
wasn't able to work yeah so and she was
a stay-at-home mom yeah yeah
um but I remember there I remember
hearing you guys discuss moving
stressfully I remember giving you my
piggy bank right yes that's right yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah well you were a
generous kid
for someone who grew up to be the evil
capitalist yeah but you always had that
capitalist aspect and you were always
motivated by money you know and you're
always pissed off if you bought
something that didn't work too that was
funny to watch you do man there was
nothing more irritated than Michaela
when she was sick she'd go spend some
money in like a department store and buy
a piece of junk it's like took her like
two years to recover if that happened
but we can only earn money when I when
you first started to use injections with
your autoimmune uh medication we wanted
to transfer you the responsibility of
doing the needles because you obviously
didn't like having needles and we
thought if you could learn to do it
that it would be under your control it
would be a Mastery and it would be less
stressful for you and so the first time
that we did that I offered you and you
were young I offered you I think 50
bucks if you could do it within 40
minutes right said I'll give you 50
bucks again you sit on time oh yeah you
sit on those stairs you see if you can
do this yourself I'll give you 50 bucks
I missed an entire episode of The
Simpsons could hear you guys watching it
downstairs yeah that's traumatic so no
no we're all sitting there with a needle
we didn't get to watch The Simpsons that
was the only TV show I let the kids
watch by the way which I also thought
was extremely hilarious but not itching
scratchy yeah you had to cover your eyes
itchy and scratch cover your eyes
anyways you know you it took you about
35 minutes before you did it yeah and
then the next time I said I think I
because I didn't want to give her 50
bucks like three times a day
so although I really wouldn't have cared
I think the next time it's like 30 bucks
in 20 minutes and we got you down so
five dollars it was five dollars a
needle is pretty cheap you know you mean
that was that that at the end that was
at the end of it yeah right right but we
also whittled down the amount of time
right so that you had to do it in
narrower yeah amounts of time but the
point of that was that we could always
use money as a motivator for you and I
don't know why that was I mean some
people are more entrepreneurially
motivated by temperament capacity yeah
you can't pay some people I've noticed
this hiring people like sometimes you
hire somebody and this is rare but you
you bring them in and they go I finished
everything you asked me to do can I do
more yeah those are rare people and
those are very useful people and if you
want to earn money that's the person you
have to be is I've done everything you
asked me to do I did it really quickly
it's all done can I do anything else I
want to do more yeah and then you make
more money it's like it's rare that that
isn't rewarded right the average person
you hire then they have a set outline of
responsibilities and if you ask them to
do anything over that I just oh that's
not part of my job yeah I don't want to
work any extra we need to emphasize that
for everybody who's listening you've got
to understand this that's
your job isn't the minimal set of
responsibilities that you have that
someone else delivers to you if that's
how you construe your job and then you
think well well I've done my job I've
done enough it's like I don't care how
much you've done it's not enough now
you're never gonna make more well well
why the answer is you want to be the
person that the person who has the
opportunities turns to and gives you
more opportunities that's who you want
to be and the way you do that is by
doing what Michaela just said it's like
you do everything you're supposed to do
as fast as you can and and and properly
and then you might ask for what else you
could do but if you're even smarter you
look around and you think what around
here hasn't been done that I could do
and then if you're even smarter than
that
you don't do that invisibly right
because then you end up a martyr you
know you're mopping up things that maybe
other people should have done but no one
notices you want to go to your employer
and say look here's what you asked me to
do here's how I did it like I had a
schedule and under budget then here's a
bunch of other things I found to do and
I did them and then you know you tell
your and that's partly how you
you don't blow your own horn right but
you're acting as your own Advocate you
bring it to the person's attention you
say look you know I did the things you
want and a bunch of other things and
then if the person's busy and has
opportunities in any sense they think
the next time a problem comes up they
think Hmm now I've got a problem a new
opportunity who should I oh yeah yeah
that kid yeah I'll give that opportunity
to him you know you'll see people in
your life you think those people are
lucky it's like sometimes they are and
you can get unlucky and that's for sure
but they're often not exactly lucky it's
their they are if an opportunity comes
their way they don't think they're
better than the goddamn opportunity and
so and you think well that's not how the
world really works it's all about power
and exploitation it's like have it your
way man live that way and and then it'll
be true and you'll be in you'll be in
like Progressive hell and so I wouldn't
recommend that it's much better to do
this yeah what what's the next thing I
can do okay so you liked you liked the
fact with Peterson Academy that it's an
opportunity rather than something that's
really being thrust on you as a like
life or death problem yeah yeah yeah
that's fun that's fun and you've liked
solving the social media puzzle part
what else do you like about it and
offering this opportunity to people
because that's a fun thing to be to be
participating in and you know the
open-ended aspect of that's cool too
because we have no idea where this might
go you know like in principle we could
offer
you know hundreds of thousands of people
a high quality University degree for
five thousand dollars right so that's
that's a ridiculously interesting
what would you say world to step into if
that's possible I also do like the
aspect like I didn't enjoy my University
experience and it was before
universities were as well because they
were but I was at an art school in
Montreal called Concordia and it was
already woke uh and it was really
frustrating to because I had like loans
and things and it was frustrating to pay
for courses
and they were terrible the professor
wasn't interesting I was like I'm pretty
sure what they just said wasn't true
right I got a psychology Professor tell
me rats weren't social creatures because
they lived in cages literally that
happened and I was like did you hear
what he said he said she was like yeah
just like you know listen to to him it's
like what not traveling 40 minutes to go
to this class and so that was
frustrating and then I was taking place
or get out in the wild and build wire
cages and then yeah yeah so yeah so they
could be so they could be Lonesome rats
yeah um and so I think it's funny too
and I think it's cruel that people are
told they have to go to university they
have to spend 100 to 200 000 to get a
degree so they can get a job otherwise
they're screwed that's such a lie it's
just a scam
I think the entire thing is a scam right
now you can learn whatever you want
online I think we have the upper hand
from just random Youtube because it's
going to be edited and we have access to
professors
um and we can give everybody access to
these like world-class professors but um
it bothers me it doesn't bother me like
a health issue but it bothers me that
people are being scammed to learn to
you know not believe in themselves
assume that they can't fix their
problems and then hate their country
basically but and it'll cost you two
hundred thousand dollars so if you
weren't resentful before you definitely
will be now but it's not our fault yeah
and then that'll just be evidence that
the system is exactly impressive yeah
yeah everything's oppressive well what's
the proof of that well just wait till
you feel wait till you see how you feel
about the university that taught you
that everything was oppressive yeah and
then you'll see that everything is
oppressive including the university yeah
yeah so now but you also said that you
think it's funny on the financial side
so what's the what's the joke
what's the joke
I think it's funny that we have the
opportunity and I don't know how big
it's going to get but I think it would
be funny if we could blow apart the
university system a little bit because
it's broken because of what it did to
you like you were alienated out of your
job basically
so I mean that's part of the joke I
think that's funny I think it's funny
that I went to University
we'll see who cancels who exactly that's
sort of funny that kind of funny oh yeah
that kind of funny I think it's funny
that like I went to two different
universities I did like half a degree in
Classics and then half degree in
biomedical science and then I ended up
quitting and working for you so I don't
have a degree I think it'd be funny to
get a degree from a university that
we're building I think that's funny too
um and I think it's weird and funny that
we're in a situation that we might be
able to make this work and we might be
able to change the education system
that's funny it's weird it's so weird
more than funny but yeah well that's
that's part of the weirdness of
Adventure so I've been writing this new
book um called we who wrestle with gold
it's coming out in February and it's
good how's that going it's going great
I'm I'm having quite the blast writing
it although it's hard on me because it's
a it's a foundation book yeah so it's
it's it's hard to do and it's it's kind
of like it it kind of rattles me up I
spent like three weeks in a monastery
just outside of Vienna writing a big
chunk of it and that was a really good
place to be it was very calm and
peaceful and beautiful and you know like
I was dealing with foundational stories
and they rattle you up you know because
you'll read one especially if you get an
insight into it it just kind of takes
you out and so there's some real
psychological Challenge and that's
frightening you know for when some of
these stories open up and you realize
what they're pointing to it kind of
scares you to your core and and that's
unsettling even though it might be
necessary
and I was writing about Abraham
and there's a characterization of
divinity in Abraham and the
characterization of divinity is
Adventure so God in the story of Abraham
is the Instinct that calls you to
Adventure and so Abraham is enticed out
of his security because he comes from
Rich parents he's privileged to know and
he could just lay around in his tent and
he'd peeled grapes from like servant
girls for his whole life but this voice
comes to him says he's like 70 when this
happens get the hell out of your comfort
zone and out into the world and Abraham
decides to listen and then you know all
hell breaks Loops because he has a rough
time of it like famine and War and
betrayal and like he has the whole
adventure of life
right but but the thing that's very
interesting about that is that even
though it's much less comfortable than
just the infantile Bliss that his life
starts out with it's it's got this
glorious aspect to it right it's this
triumphant Vikings on the high sea get
the hell out and have an adventure
Through the Jungle element to its
romantic adventure fundamentally and one
of the things I've realized as a
consequence of of walking through that
book is that what people want in life
isn't
security and it isn't happiness
it's they want what they will pay for
when they go see a movie they want a
romantic adventure you know and if you
have a problem that's in front of you
like the collapse of the education
system the adventure is well you know
can we confront that problem head on and
enter into a world where
our adventure is
doing whatever is necessary to solve
that problem and that is that it's got
that joke-like aspect to it in the most
positive sense but it's also it's also
the adventure of calling and meaning and
you know and it is I know too you know
when I was really sick when I wrote my
last book because I was really sick when
I wrote my last book
um I could barely sit and I spent a
number of hours most days writing and
you know I was still really sick even
though I was writing but
at least
I had a terrible problem to solve and
thank God for that right because
that's what you want this is something
people don't understand is you know you
think I have a problem I don't want to
have a problem it's like yeah actually
you probably should thank God that you
have a problem that that grips you you
know
now it's going to depend on your
attitude towards the problem but
there's no difference between a problem
and a glorious Adventure if you
if you organize yourself properly
in terms of conceptualizing the problem
maybe you'll like one's a little bit
more painful
well
you know if you had your druthers you'd
probably want the opportunity rather
than the problem but but there's an
opportunity in problems well but then
also you're going to have problems so so
even if you'd rather have the
opportunity which you should rather have
if you're saying you still need an
attitude
to help you with the fact that you're
going to have a problem you know in one
of the right attitudes is well you know
the bigger the dragon the larger the
treasure
and that's actually yeah that's actually
true it's the deepest it might be the
deepest human truth that's why it's the
core of the hero myth
you know and and it's it's a weird
it's weird that the world might be
constituted in that way but
well why wouldn't the greatest reward
come to the person who solves the most
intractable problem
like you know it's kind of obvious when
you think about it that way
so yeah yeah yeah so so it's nice to
have a heart problem and then you have
something to
sink your teeth into yeah and if you
have no idea what you want to do with
your life that's where you should start
like what's wrong with it okay fix that
right or at least it won't be as bad
right yeah absolutely well that's
another thing you learn as a behavioral
psychologist like people will come and
say well I'm miserable it's like well
let's get specific
what sucks about your life like
specifically and so then the person they
might have to talk to you for 100 hours
to detail out that and then the next
part is okay what sucks about your life
that you would like to change and you
could see differently right because
sometimes some person will have a
problem you can say well what do you
want to do about that and they go well I
don't know or I can't do anything or I
can't but then but there's a subset of
problems where you say well
how could you change this so it was
better and they have an idea
and then there's a smaller subset where
you can say well is there some problems
that you see a solution to that you see
a pathway towards solving and they'll
say well I could do this hey
do that do that and that's a humility
that's humility right because you have
to first of all you have to admit that
you don't know everything I have
problems then you have to admit some of
them are Beyond you
then you have to admit that
there's some that you could address that
you haven't because you're useless
and then you have to admit that this is
the step that you could take no matter
how small it is so you get there by you
get there on your knees you get there
through humility it's like but then if
you start this is what's cool about it
if you start local and low
then
and you do it religiously
you'll get better at solving problems
very rapidly so it doesn't really matter
where you start tired of doing it yeah
yeah and that starts to scale really
quickly this episode was sponsored by
schwank grills if you want to impress
your friends and get Morton's or
high-end Steakhouse level Stakes this is
a grill you can use in your backyard or
patio that works I've used it it's
really high quality schwank grills gives
a mired reaction crust like high-end
steakhouses they're also portable so now
Steakhouse style steaks are an option
while camping if you want to get really
bougie schwed girls also offers a 14-day
guarantee and these guys were good
enough to get my audience 150 off by
using code mp150 at checkout at
schwankgrills.com as someone who only
eats meat how you cook the meat matters
and it's basically impossible to beat
1500 degree grilled steaks at home go to
schwangirls.com and use code mp150
that's s-c-h-w-a-n-k-g-r-i-l-l-s.com
code mp150 to save 150 the links in the
comments below enjoy the rest of this
episode we're almost out of time can we
talk about two things sure okay one
um I've been getting
fairly tortured on Twitter about this
Andrew Tate thing
hmm are you okay with addressing that
sure okay so I think first before we get
started and I only want to talk about
this once because I'm very bored of this
um delve into this too much but
I think a bit of clarification on my end
in 2019
I was in Germany
and Andrew Tate bought me tickets to fly
to Romania
to go to discuss business and then to
fly back to Canada
and the reason I went was because in
when you Googled Andrew Tate he came up
as a millionaire kickboxer
he had ideas about a subscription
platform for me and for you
and
I think part of the way because of how I
grew up I basically said yes to
Opportunities and I didn't see a reason
to not go talk to a millionaire about
how he made money and I also got the
benefit of a ticket home and I was also
already in Germany so I didn't see a
reason not to go that's also probably
partly because I used to say yes to any
opportunity which I also think is part
of the reason why I'm successful now so
anyway I went there
from my experience I met Andrew and I
met his brother Tristan
they were very nice to me like they were
nice to me we had a fun time there the
reason that there's a rumor there's a
rumor online that we hooked up or we
slept together or something that didn't
happen I've told people that numerous
times it's not like I was a yeah well
people 20 year old girl like enamored
versions online too it's one of the
things I've really seen that that troll
demons like to go after women on that
front right yeah yeah yeah it's really
so it's like a backbiting behavior and
it doesn't matter what I say he's
dispelled it doesn't matter
um
anyway I haven't really commented on the
situation because when I went they were
nice to me like I actually had a pretty
good time he drove me around in his
Bugatti and we saw castles which was a
weird experience I remember telling he
was in very very very smart person
[Music]
um and I remember telling him you kind
of remind me of a human shark I don't
know like what it was but I was like
you're it's interesting I don't know if
it's your eyes or something but you kind
of remind me of a human shark
that was it
and then I flew home so that that's the
story on my end now I wanted to address
that because people have been bothering
me on Twitter for like two years or
three years because of pictures of us uh
smoking cigars or having a vodka or
something because
I did
um
and it was fun but that's it that's the
story on my end do you think you made
any mistakes in in that venture
well I had no idea he was going to
become like the most famous person in
the entire world
um would that have changed it
I don't think so like from knowing what
I knew at the time
I would have still gone
um
from knowing more about the webcam of
stuff and he told me about so once I was
there he told me about the webcam stuff
what did he do not not in detail okay I
can't remember like that well but it was
something like women who want to do
webcam stuff like they already want to
do it I helped them make way more money
and I take a percentage
and so I was like okay
I didn't I don't think you know I wasn't
like that seems like a wonderful
business model but I was like if there
are women who are already doing it and
now they're making more money I guess it
doesn't seem
you know it is what it is kind of but I
didn't know that until I got there and
then he he wanted to set up subscription
platforms
um and said they could be very valuable
and
and we'd already been kind of looking
into that because you'd had some issues
with social media I was worried you're
going to get banned on sites and so I
was already thinking it would be good to
set that up with a subscription well
Gmail canceled me at one point yeah I
know that about that yeah it was
ridiculous so it's like it would be good
to learn how to do the subscription
platform
um anyway
that so I kind of went there to like
scope things out and it was a very
interesting experience and they were
nice to me that's like the story yeah
well the it I hesitate to talk about
Andrew Tate because I don't know that
much about him you know that but I'll
I'll tell you what I know and what I
think and people can take it for what
it's worth I mean the first question is
why is he so popular and the answer is
well if you have to choose between being
depressed and anxious and laying
downstairs and covering yourself with
Cheeto dust and looking at pornography
and being timid and never going out or
you know listening to someone like
Andrew Tate who says like get the hell
out there and take the world like that's
better that's the shadow right speaking
in some ways right like if you're naive
and timid and anxious and intimidated
and useless and resentful there's going
to be a bit of a monster that needs to
call to you to say you know gird up your
loins and get the hell out there in the
world and so it's better to be it's
better to be a monster than a rabbit in
some ways right or at least there's some
utility in the more monstrous predatory
path that isn't there in the pathetic
rabbit path and that's partly because if
you are a pathetic rabbit you're going
to become a predator anyways you're just
going to become a dark back door
backbiting gossip-mongering resentful
monster Society is also pushing that on
men and yes
look I know I knew and I warned people
repeatedly that if the culture kept
emasculating men that men who said to
hell with that I'd rather be a monster
would become extremely popular now in
Andrew Tate
is emblematic of that many ways because
the first thing you got to say about him
is that he's genuinely tough
right so that's not a front that's not a
front he's a fighter and and you can't
take the courageous element of being a
fighter away from someone who will
actually step in the ring right and so
now and and then
you said Tate's intelligent and what
that means as well is that some of the
things he says are going to be of value
now why he says those that's a whole
different issue the the thing that
disturbs me is that like I'm not very
fond of the whole online porn thing in
any way and I don't think that it's okay
for young women to monetize their sexual
attractiveness online I think that leads
to a very dark place for them even if
they're successful because becoming very
successful
you don't become successful
by exploiting yourself and you might
think well I can exploit myself it's
like you can't treat yourself like a
psychopath would treat you and get away
with it even if the psychopath that's
doing that is yourself that doesn't work
that's why Psychopaths aren't very
successful because they exploit
themselves just like other people and so
I don't like the whole online porn thing
and then I don't now my understanding
and and I've watched him apparently
agree to this characterization online
you know it's hard to get a I'm not
trying to be the jury here because I
haven't heard the whole damn story but
from what I've watched as he would
enter into relationships with women and
tilt them in the direction of
generating like in only fans following
and monetize that and then take a
percentage and there isn't anything
about that that I think is acceptable
you know and you could say well you know
women are the captains of their own soul
and if they want to monetize their own
attractiveness then what the hell why
not do it and if they're going to do it
anyways you know I can help them and if
I help them why not take a piece of the
action and the answer is to me the
answer to that is well how about because
it's ignoble and wrong now you could you
could counter you could say well you're
just too useless and timid to dare to do
that
right and and I'd say you know point
taken you know Nietzsche had pointed
this out back in the 1850s he said most
morality is cowardice in the guise of
morality it's not like it's not like I'm
good it's just that I'm afraid to do
that and Tate would say well if you're
just not doing something because you're
a coward that doesn't mean you're good
and whereas I'm forthright and tough and
look at me I climb into the ring and you
know I can entice women into you know
sex work online and take a cut and why
the hell shouldn't I and I think that if
you're a timid and reprehensible
resentful bottom dwelling male that
that's going to look like an attractive
alternative but
but it's not the highest form of human
behavior right it's not it's not
acceptable like I think pimps of any
sort are I truly believe they're amongst
the most contemptible of people I think
there's nothing in you know with a pimp
as well I've got all these hoes and look
at me like you know king of these women
and it's like no you are the ultimate
empathetic parasitic Predators there's
nothing about that that's heroic it's
just pathetic now you might say if
you're that type well at least is I'm
not as contemptible as the cowards Who
hide behind me it's like fair enough you
know there's there's ranks of order even
in hell and there's lower and higher
demons you know and the person who would
like to do something terrible but is too
cowardly to do it that's a pretty damn
low form of demon but that doesn't mean
that the person who would like to do
something in is courageous enough to do
it even though it's bad isn't also a
demon and so you know I think
fundamentally that Tate serves his his
immediate self in this like impulsive
gratifying Manner and I think that goes
along with his you know look at me I'm
in a Bugatti it's like you know fair
enough man
in some way do you think what he's been
telling men more on the you know take
responsibility for your life and and do
things if that I mean it's hard to I
suppose separate it from an actual life
people are complex no villain is simple
no no villain is simple you know and and
in in great literature
the great villain is a sympathetic
figure you're kind of on board for 75
percent of it and not only that you you
might also say well if I was in that
position I might do the same thing like
it's only a cartoon villain who's 100
evil right and so even when you meet
someone who's dark and Psychopathic to
the core you'll find and I've had
clients who were like I had one client
who had like five restraining orders out
against him he was actually quite
comical he's Curtis a young guy small
guy kind of slight extremely intense you
know he had that kind of human shark
thing going and he was actually he was
quite the horrible riotest blast to work
with because he was he was a very
interesting monster and he would five
restraining orders is a lot and
restraining orders don't work on the
sort of people who need restraining
orders so don't be ever think in
restraining order is going to help you
not if a real monsters caught you in his
sights and he he had a paranoid end to
him and what that meant was
if he was ever insulted by you he would
blow the insult up and it would put
enmity between the two of you so like
talking to him was quite the nightmare
because you didn't get to make a mistake
and he was hyper Vigilant because he was
paranoid so he's just watching you like
a bloody Hawk for every deviation from
honesty and like I never lied to him and
if I thought he was doing something
stupid and terrible I just told him that
I looks to me like that's pretty stupid
and terrible like there was no I wasn't
playing with him and I wasn't trying to
impress him and I talked to him for a
long time but he would uh
he would
I remember he told me one time about
going into a bank you know and he met
one of those tellers that you know you
go into an institution sometimes you
meet somebody with bureaucratic
personality disorder and they decide
that the good thing to do that day is to
just screw up your life
just because they can it's my job right
right yeah well you know I have to do
this and they're they're playing their
little power game because they're like
dos dfc's underground man and they're
resentful to the core and so they're
going to just screw around with you well
now and then someone would do that with
him
and he'd say I'm going to be your worst
nightmare and then what he meant was I'm
now going to commit a sizable proportion
of my life and all my intellectual
prowess to making you as miserable as I
can possibly imagine and then he would
go do that you know and there was
actually oh this isn't yeah oh yeah oh
yeah maybe I shouldn't be a bureaucratic
nightmare well right right well and then
see that well and that was the weirdly
admirable part right it's like you know
because typically what would happen in a
situation like that is you'd go into the
bank and you'd just swallow it then
you'd go out and you know go home and
kick your dog and at your wife
because you didn't tell the bureaucrat
to you know watch the hell out or
something terrible is going to happen
well he was way on the other end of the
distribution it's like don't muck with
me and he meant he was an honor code guy
it's like don't knock with me and what
he meant was
don't muck with me now and he meant it
and there was something admirable about
that you know even though he was a very
dangerous person and he had taken it way
too far but this is what I mean by
complexity of the villain it's like well
he had the courage of his convictions
let's put it that way you know and so
when you see someone like Andrew Tate
well first of all if you have any sense
you think this is a guy that's actually
crawled in the ring and the second thing
you think is well just because his moral
compass is Warped and warped in a
serious way on the like electronic pimp
front and like I think in a fable way
personally that's the highest likelihood
because I don't think you can do that
without permeating everything that
doesn't mean that you know he's a
two-dimensional villain you know or that
there aren't things about them that are
complex and interesting and potentially
even admirable you know people are
complicated and and even the villainous
types are complicated and it isn't
surprising to me at all that he's an
attractive figure given the current
you know war against masculinity he's
exactly the he's 100 predictable he's
exactly what you'd expect
so would you talk to him
you know why I pretty much talk to
anybody
I thought about you know whether or not
that would be a good idea for me you
know generally one of my primary driving
force is just curiosity yeah yeah and I
am a clinician you know I like talking
to I've talked to lots of
I've talked to lots of very
strange people you know lots of them and
it's very interesting to do that because
you're really wandering into no man's
land and that's perilous and
ridiculously crazily interesting that's
what I loved about partly what I loved
about being a clinician like almost
everybody is interesting enough to be a
Dostoevsky character if you start
listening to them and so just ordinary
people if you listen to them they're
ridiculously weird and interesting and
then you find someone truly weird and
interesting and listening to them listen
to them it's like you can hardly stand
it Carl Rogers talked about this you
know he said people won't listen because
they're too terrified of changing
because you know if you listen to
someone they tell you how weird they are
you share in that self-revelation it's
it's too interesting
so and I'm sure talking to Andrew Tate
would be too interesting
so
okay we should wrap up because you've
got to run but just really quick
um you you set up a donation site for
your friend Charles people have been
asking like what happened with that
how's he doing is everything okay so
just like two minutes on that and we'll
call it quits yeah yeah well
Charles
Charles is this native Canadian Carver
and uh I've had a relationship with him
for about 15 years and we got inducted
into his family six years ago something
like that was very cool and he helped me
design the third floor of my house and
it's full of all his carvings which it's
a magical place it's really a magical
place and uh
you know I've developed a relationship
with him and Charles has had a real
rough life because he he was ground
through the like sadistic residential
school nightmare in Canada not all the
residential schools were run by
pedophilic sadists but his was and so
and uh with with the effect on him that
you might imagine if you had a very dark
imagination indeed and uh
well anyways you know I bought art from
him and and helped him with his artistic
career and and and that's been of great
utility to me as well
but last year six months ago seven
months ago his wife died and he has
little kids and then his house in the
shop burned down like the same month
right and so off oh it was awful it was
awful and so you know he was left bereft
in in two different dimensions and so I
put together this fundraiser and and we
raised a fair bit of money I think about
190 000 is that about right I think
about a hundred
I could be wrong I think it was less
okay but something like that well and
then I thought well you know we we're
looking for investment places generally
anyways and so what we ended up doing
was buying a house about property for
him on Vancouver Island
um back in the neighborhood that he was
familiar with and it's a beautiful place
it's like this you know acreage it's
beautiful old wood house it's got a shop
outside where he could carve and
um his kids are there now with him and
I'm going to see him tomorrow probably
oh yeah or sometime this week because
I'm going to Vancouver Island and and he
sent me some pictures recently he
started to carve again and you know he's
recovering from the loss of his wife and
his kids seem really happy there and
it's a beautiful unbelievably beautiful
property sort of nestled in the
mountains and can people buy his masks
online Charles joseph.ca okay cool I'll
link that yeah they're very good yeah
he's a great artist a real Visionary a
very strange person because he was
trained in this ancient West Coast
native tradition they had an unbroken
cultural lineage of it least it's more
than fifteen thousand years that's about
when they probably got down to the West
Coast but it was an unbroken tradition
stretching from way before that and so
I've also learned a fair bit on the
anthropological front about hit the
mythology of his people and their
artistic tradition and how that makes
itself manifest in him like he dreams
his carving characters he dreams in the
genre that he carves and he can talk to
his great grandparents in his dreams
about the carving problems that he has
and he doesn't talk about this generally
you know because he says I talk about
this and everybody thinks he's crazy
Charles is not crazy Charles is one deep
character man you've watched him dance
oh my gosh yeah yeah yeah when we had
that um event where we got inducted I
don't want to say it wrong yes
um there was this event it was wild it
was like you could feel things in there
oh yeah yeah he really turns into
whatever he dances like it's fully grips
him fully you know and and and he's
gripped fully when he's carving too and
it's really been great to have these I
like I've always loved the West Coast
Canadian native art ever since I was a
little kid and so he's he bought a 38
foot Cedar pole that he's going to make
for us say for our house our Cottage
cool yeah yeah and so it's going to have
a two serpents at the base and then two
women negative and positive and then two
men and then a hero figure out the top
yeah so a real shamanic totem pole yeah
we've been working on the design for
that so anyways he said he's thrilled to
be there he seems he got away the the
reserve he was on was full of trouble
there were people there that were
bothered him to death including like you
know demented social workers and he's
just pulled himself away from that and
so I'm hoping he'll be set now so that
he can just devote himself to carving
and you know it's complicated
relationship because he has a
complicated life
um you know I mean
um his community in general like most of
the Native communities in North America
is pretty damn devastated and there's
people around him dying all the time of
one problem or another like his life is
in some ways a never-ending sequence of
tragic catastrophes and complexities and
you know it's it's complex being
involved in that but but I I really like
Charles he's a great guy and and I don't
mean in the isn't he nice he makes a
good friend I mean Charles is a great
person he's really deep and uncanny in
many ways and so because you don't go
what he went through what he went
through and recover
without
having things moved around profoundly in
the depths and he's really a good artist
he's a real Visionary and so he's quite
the strange person to be around and so
you know it's it's an adventure being in
association with him but it has been a
real interesting Adventure going to that
Potlatch was you know like How likely is
that zero right it's zero likely so you
know we went to this when I when we got
inducted into his family we went to this
ceremony that lasted what 12 hours in
this Indian big house it was a number of
days Yeah well yeah it went over that's
right it went over a couple of days
that's right right continual dancing and
masks and he made like 50 or 60 masks
for that Festival I bought all those
masks so I have a complete Potlatch
collection which is also very cool and
you know it was a real trip it was
something I never thought would happen
it was a trip yeah
yeah okay on that note all right thank
you very much for coming on thanks for
the opportunity with Peterson Academy
hey welcome thanks for running with the
football there kiddo and it'll be fun to
see how it all turns out it's so far you
know everybody who's been involved has
said very positive things and I've seen
you know a fair bit of the edited
footage which was great yeah everybody
who's working so far is great
yeah yeah yeah well that's a good thing
to know too you know if you're going to
set up a business if you're watching and
listening you want to set up a business
you find people who are great who are
great that's what you're looking for you
want you don't want well their
confidence like no
no if you want to stay involved in what
you're doing and you wanna
push it all the way you're looking for
100 percent all in on board great and
you're looking for people if a problem
emerges
hopefully the problems don't emerge
because they solved them before they
emerge but if they do emerge they deal
with them they put it right and then
they don't have the same problem again
and you have to be pretty damn
separate the wheat from the chaff rough
if you're going to run an Enterprise and
make it work and you've you've got very
good at that you know in in making sure
that the people who are on board are
100 percent on board and firing on all
cylinders and then it's a blast to do
something
and then you can also give people the
space for their own adventure because if
you hire really competent people and
they share the vision
you can give them a piece and say you
know have at her man this is your
territory and that's also extremely fun
and enables you to do all sorts of other
things this is why you shouldn't
micromanage it's like you want to spend
your life micromanaging or you want to
distribute responsibility
so that people can have their own
adventure well then you'll be jealous of
that if you're an idiot but if you're
not if they have their responsibility
and their piece of the pie well then you
can go do something else yeah right and
that's a big deal you know when I made
the business arrangements with you and
Julian you know my tack was
I want to make you a deal that you're so
thrilled with that I never have to worry
about whether our interests are aligned
because it's just obvious you know
because you got what you needed not what
you wanted or to get the upper hand but
you know the negotiation was honest what
do you need so you're thrilled to be
doing this
you want to make this Arrangement your
bloody well want to make in your
marriage too it's like what do I have to
do to set up this marriage so that
you're thrilled to be in it
yeah I think it's also fun because I get
to work with Jordan on everything yeah
and why is that even key very smart yeah
it's good at firing people he's good at
identifying problems and fixing them
he's very competent
so he can just take on like he knows the
business from the ground up too he's the
one who helped find people to film and
like structure that entire thing he's
more familiar with tech on that side
than I am
and he has a OCD eye for detail as well
how do you balance your your personal
relationship with your business
relationship
um well we're pretty good at
communicating and I'm pretty
we're both extremely disagreeable he's
extremely disagreeable I'm at least I've
got some compassion on my end
um but I think I'm also old enough that
I don't I'm not going to not say things
that bother me so there's nothing hidden
and then how do we manage it
our goals are aligned I think is how we
manage it yeah yeah so we've got like
sometimes we bicker a little bit about
certain decisions but
not very often because there also isn't
sometimes I'm wrong well there isn't
there's a difference often if the
bickering is in good faith there isn't
much difference in yeah yeah exactly
thinking it's like if you're thinking
you're bickering with yourself
right it's like what could be this or it
could be that it's like well you don't
know which is why you do the thinking
and you know the the stress that occurs
between couples often at least if it's
good faith a fair bit of that is well
it's a complicated problem and there's
going to be a couple of different
viewpoints of course you have to have it
out yeah that's unpleasant in the moment
but this is something I think we did
fairly effectively in our families like
we didn't let problems
hide under the carpet it was like
letting that sucker out we'll have a
scrap about it right now
and that's you know that's stressful
because you have the damn fights but
then then at least in principle they're
over
yeah so we do that but
it's probably less dramatic than it was
in our family we're a bit of a dramatic
family okay okay we have to end this
thank you very much for coming on all
right well good luck with the
revitalization of your podcast thank you
the second million subscribers thank you
yeah you bet you bet yep if you guys
would like to be notified of the launch
of Peterson Academy you can go to
petersonacademy.com and sign up there
and I'll be putting a link to everything
we talked about including
petersonacademy.com in the description
thanks for watching